et en france la question du surpoids est
un problème de plus en plus préoccupant
près de 6 millions de personnes seraient
concernées par l'obésité c'est
d'ailleurs pour tenter de lutter contre
ce problème de santé publique qu'une
campagne est lancée aujourd'hui comme
pour le tabac comme pour l'alcool de
nouveaux messages on apparaître sur
certains produits
explication nicolas lemarignier diane
richard attention il faut être très
attentif désormais en bas des pubs pour
les produits gras ou sucrés il aura un
petit tout petit quelque chose en plus
pour votre santé ne mangez pas trop gras
pas trop sucré pas trop salée pour tous
les produits sucrés ou gras les
industriels de l'alimentaire doivent
inclure dans leurs publicités un message
sanitaire
il y en a quatre au total par exemple
pour votre santé pratiquez une activité
physique régulière pour votre santé
manger au moins cinq fruits et légumes
par jour
les fabricants qui n'affiche pas les
petites phrases devront payer une taxe
pour financer la lutte contre l'obésité
ils seront peu nombreux car affiché son
intérêt pour la santé du consommateur
c'est aussi un argument marketing
c'est vrai que depuis trois ou quatre
ans ce phénomène de visites et de la
lumière ce qu'un jour dans au plus
important est elle tout d'un coup une
mobilisation globale à la fois des
scientifiques à la fois des politiques
industrielles pour traiter ce sujet dont
tant que grandes enseignes
il est bien entendu de notre robe
prendrait en compte à terme un spot sur
3 comportera un message sanitaire
mais ces avertissements sont ils
efficaces non répond l'ufc que choisir
qui a mené l enquête
on sait très bien que la tension elle
est d'abord capté par le film pas par un
message qui va se dérouler en bas de
l'écran on sait très bien qu'à à 6,7 en
la capacité de lecture des enfants est
pas suffisante pour s'intéresser à ce
message qui va lire et encore plus à le
comprendre
les nutritionnistes aurait aimé que l'on
interdise les réclames qui vise les
enfants
les industriels ont refusé de tirer un
trait sur un marché publicitaire de 2
milliards d'euros par an